all right so diving right in what is it
about nimona that like Drew you to the
project I was mainly first drawn um
having been a huge fan of NDS prior to
my casting so knowing that this was an
incredible story already on Page in
graphic novel form that was also
inherently queer and created by a queer
person I mean that was kind of like you
you already had me sold and then let
alone being approached to voice acting
it I was over the moon what is it then
about and Brazil specifically
that that kind of hooked you as a
character you wanted to play yeah I feel
like Ambrosius is such a great
representation of this idea of being
stuck between this sense of what you're
being told is Right versus what you feel
you know is right and that is something
that everyone can relate to at some
point in their lives with him it's like
really deeply tied to his identity as
like the hero of the realm and that's
something that I've always related to
especially as an Asian American as a
queer person this idea of Performing the
duties and the Honors that I've been
told in the systems I live in and then
bucking that in the end that's Ambrosia
to a T and that's a lot of my life did
you get the chance like I know this is
based on the graphic novel but did you
get the chance to kind of have input
with the creative team to expand
Ambrosius from where he was on the page
to now what we see on screen yeah I
think that a lot of that was done by the
writers who did such an incredible job
of translating this particular version
of golden loin and from for me I think
what was really cool was you know I
ad-libbed quite a bit in the booth and
so there were like small changes that
were made here and there that fit the
I guess the the situation more in
certain scenes and a lot of that was I
think
you know they they knew that he had to
have a certain amount of charm to him to
be believable as this like hero but also
at the same time he's going through a
lot of bad stuff with his his man and so
that aspect like I mean you can't really
teach that I was just pulling from
experience I was like oh God this is
like me fighting with my boyfriend so
that's that's was I think where there
was quite a bit of like ah he's we can
Source some of that that uh personal
strife and use it as part of his
character it's been like a standout
ad-lib that you can remember that you
just thought yes
love this yeah I mean there there was a
point in the film where he imagines that
he like actually has an outburst with
the the director and it's something that
um most of that was written but it
changed quite a bit and I also there's
takes of me just just screaming for
three minutes about just absolutely
whack the wackiest things
um and I think that was uh one of the
first times in the booth that I really
felt like oh this character is going to
be such a great example of of a stressed
out person who's trying to do his job
but really is should should also try to
to honor his his one true love what
would you say if there were any like
specific challenges that came with with
adapting this story for the screen yeah
I think that the challenges is that you
know it's always hard to
um update or translate something from
from book form and ND being a part of
the process and also I know he likes the
film he loves the film it's it's a
different version of the story but I
think a lot of that was you know I
believe truly that the one thing that
makes this film really work is making
sure that pneumonia is
her spirit everything about her needs to
be translated the most directly to
screen because that's what made the
graphic novel so successful and really
impactful and I think it's it's been
achieved it does such a great job
pneumona's such a such a cool lovable
complex weird chaotic character and so
they they really really nailed that and
on my personal level I just really love
on screen that the Ambrosius and
baluster relationship is is established
unabashedly up top in the film and that
they're really tender with each other
the entire time like even when they're
fighting they're very tender and I think
that's that was a really cool choice
that was made I like how how explicit
that was made like right off the top
because the graphic novel does take a
minute to get there yeah but five
seconds into seeing them I'm like I hope
these two and then immediately and it
was just so you're like boyfriends
yes boyfriends
I don't have to delude myself for two
hours they are boyfriends absolutely
there's no will they won't they it's
like they did they did they had they
will
they are they still are
so
we can say spoiler free but is there a
specific moment you are most excited for
audiences to see yeah I mean you know I
think the climax of the film is really
really impactful and important and the
line that's delivered
um I see you at a particular part is
just such a it's such a
graceful simple message that is lost on
so many people out there right now this
idea that if you just can recognize that
someone is different or struggling or
just wants to have uh the validation of
someone saying like I care about what
you're going through I care about who
you are that is like the bottom line and
that's what nimona needed that's what a
lot of viewers I think might need and I
think that is like that's the standout
um message for me that you walk away
from the film with and then is that the
message you hope that's the message you
hope that audiences take away at the end
is that yeah the importance of being
seen the importance of being seen I also
love the message I hope they take away
the feeling of like find little ways to
Rebel in in the institutions that are
trapping you like you know there's
there's some healthy uh proactive ways
you can do that I love that I love that
turn into your version of a whale
I just turn into your version of a whale
whatever that means whatever that means
to you